let's do politics quickly we have an
election next year in the US that you've
said is the most important election in
our lifetime uh you see populist on both
sides uh of the debate how do you what's
the end result there well I think we can
all see that we have irreconcilable
differences by sides that will if that's
what I mean by populism irreconcilable
Difference by uh sides that will not
accept losing and so you're seeing an
emergence even um an emergence of uh
should the Supreme Court matter and do
you put people in jail and all of this
kind of extremism so one side can't beat
the other and no no good government no
good Society exists with this kind of
fighting and this is not good governance
this has big implications it has big
economic and tax implications and uh
money implications who do you get the
money for so so this is something that
people will fight over in their very
ways if it's not resolved what we need
is a very strong middle okay we have to
reform the system in a lot of ways to
make sure it's great for most people and
that's a whole other yeah I'd love to
have that conversation with you sometime
because it's absolutely critical but it
sounds like you think there's at least a
chance that we don't end up with the
Trump Biden election yeah the
interesting election the interesting
race is going to begin really probably
around South Carolina after that right
around that between the alternative and
Trump yeah something to watch